Katie Holmes and Jamie Foxx are still  going strong you clarify you're not  dating Katie so the pair has yet to  confirm their relationship a source  tells ET Jamie and Katie are quote very  much in a serious relationship you're  never going to please everyone here's  what we know about the pair's our  rumored romance that began back in  August 2013 according to our source the  sleepless actor recently surprised  Holmes with a congratulatory bouquet of  flowers during her press tour for the  Kennedys after Camelot as for why the  superstar duo continues to remain  low-key about their private life et has  learned to Foxx and Holmes prefer to  cater in for date nights what I've  learned about society today is that  they're so thirsty especially in tabloid  world and in social media world  they're so thirsty to find any type of  stories often Holmes reps have never  confirmed the alleged relationship  you